[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
friday july 22nd i'm zoe thomas for the
wall street journal
on thursday amazon announced plans to
buy onelife healthcare which operates a
primary care practice under the name one
medical in major cities across the u.s
this is not amazon's first foray into
the medical space in 2019 it launched
amazon care
originally it was a service for amazon
employees in washington state and amazon
care's telemedicine and urgent care
health offering has slowly been
expanding to employees of other
companies
but this turn to medicine has been slow
going for amazon with regulatory and
other hurdles hubbling its typically
speedy entrance into a sector
so why is the e-commerce giant so
focused on entering the medical space
and how will this purchase help joining
us to discuss this is our amazon
reporter sebastian herrera hey sebastian
thanks for joining us hey thanks for
having me
amazon already has amazon care now it's
going to be buying onelife healthcare
which has one medical
why is it interested in buying one life
health care and how does it fit into the
medical offerings that amazon already
has
yeah so amazon care really is only
existed as a telehealth sort of urgent
care service it's really imagined as a
you know you can chat with someone
online and they can send out a doctor
to a health care provider to your home
and also any medicine and that's sort of
been the limits of the service and so
with this purchase and getting one
medical it primarily it gives them to
physical spaces because one medical has
more than 180 medical offices in the u.s
so that is already a big deal getting
those physical locations and it also
potentially helps them expand into
something more than just sort of urgent
care services something that looks more
like a primary care
long-term services which is i think what
any medical provider wants to get into
they don't just want those one-off
visits but those sort of long-term
established relationships with patients
so this could potentially like really
really like boost that effort and also
just
you know get the more customers that
they
obviously need to expand and so
it's sort of those different things that
come into play by purchasing one medical
i mean that's what it means for amazon
what about for patients will this change
how patients get care maybe immediately
if they're a one medical user or overall
do we think they'll be kind of a big sea
change in how we get offerings once
amazon decides to really get into the
medical section
i think at least initially it won't
change much
the one medical ceo is still going to be
there and
it's more like the whole foods
relationship where it is going to be
under amazon but it's supposed to be
working uh sort of independently in a
way um i think they're still figuring
that some of that stuff out but it's not
like amazon's just
totally taking over
and rebranding the the service and all
that so i think for patients initially
not much should change of course that
could um evolve over time
okay maybe we can dive in a little bit
more to the reasoning behind it so
obviously they're hoping this deal works
out for them but why does amazon you
know who everybody thinks of as kind of
this e-commerce provider maybe as a
cloud provider or you know if you're a
prime subscriber a video provider
why do they want to be a medical
provider as well
i think it has to deal with how big that
industry is and
some people i've referred to as like
almost like a recession-proof sort of
industry as well and so amazon it's sort
of looking for its next hit it has aws
advertising really seems to be sort of
like that potential next hit as well
it's not already becoming a hit and i
think what amazon has shown is that it's
comfortable diving into different spaces
seeing how it goes it's not afraid to
take chances and if it becomes a big
deal for them
then then great then they just sort of
like expand their horizon are more you
know built for if there's a recession or
if one business isn't doing it as good
this other business is doing great and
healthcare obviously is a potential to
make a lot of money and just be the
great connector to
to different services already provides
but providing healthcare has kind of its
own unique hurdles you know dealing with
regulatory issues and privacy concerns
how does amazon plan to deal with those
challenges
yeah i think those are like the big
questions out there right now
because
with this purchase they are potentially
going to get a troll of data from one
medical and their customers and
providers there's already some buzz out
there of regulatory concerns and how
amazon uses data i think people get
scared with any big company that sort of
has a lot of data on its hand i think
amazon will tell you right now there's
still like a really small and new
player in this space that's really big
old hard to figure out and success is by
no means guaranteed so i think there's
definitely questions out there of you
know how amazon will use the data that
it has it being such a big company
amazon is really good at gathering data
and using it to its benefit and using it
to expand and even using it in deal
making and as leverage for other
businesses
and i assume the
argument that they are still a new and
smaller player and the medical space is
also going to be their argument if if
regulators raise any anti-trust concerns
we're a big player but we're not that
big in this industry
exactly and that's an argument they've
made in the past like with retail
every time that it's brought in front of
them that they're this dominant player
in e-commerce and retail they sort of
cite figures that oh but if you compare
us to global overall retail including
you know physical locations are actually
like really small that's sort of their
argument
but yeah that's certainly a position
that you could see them taking if
they're not already taking right now
all right that's our reporter sebastian
herrera thanks so much for joining us
sebastian thank you and that's it for
tech news briefing this week our
producer is julie chang we had editorial
support from scott salloway we had
production assistants from ariana os
peru our supervising producer is chris
sinsley our executive producer is kateri
yocum and i'm your host zoe thomas
thanks for listening and have a great
weekend
[Music]
you